the new rules that take effect in less
than an hour are a real relief for many
all across the valley
madison kimbrough spoke to a local
restaurant owner about what this means
for his business
she joins us live with the latest
madison
yes on thursday governor sysolak
announced that he would be raising
capacity to 35 percent for restaurants
and businesses
now while this may not seem like a lot
from the 25 percent that we are
currently
at i spoke to one restaurant owner who
says it's a step
in the right direction indoor dining and
beverage service will be capped at 35
percent capacity
beginning february 15th businesses such
as gyms
arcades bowling alleys and restaurants
can move to 35 percent capacity
upping it by just 10 percent from what
it previously was
these easing of restrictions comes after
a drop in covet 19 cases in the state of
nevada
a lot of people seeing this as an
encouraging move that we are headed in
the right direction
like restaurant owner raymie mosca of me
peru south american grill in henderson
it's been hard i mean because keeping
under 25
is always a challenge even though most
people now order to go going to 35
is definitely going to help we want to
emphasize in people
keeping the distance still reservations
will no longer be required and six
people will be allowed per table instead
of four outdoor dining however will not
have capacity limits
but social distancing is still a must
customers like claudia shared with us
how this increase in capacity will
greatly benefit her family
in our family it's uh six of us so now
we
we have been not going out at all
because we're not going to leave two
people behind
now we can all have dinner all together
you know
instead of just not going or just you
know
it's better
and again this takes effect tonight at
midnight and public gatherings and
events can have
up to 100 people or 35 percent whichever
is less
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now